Allen tell us where you were when you
came up with the idea for Bob's new suit
where were you in your life where had
you been how did the idea come about
very interesting question I had been
trying to get several independent films
financed and as you probably know that
is very difficult and I was actually
quite confused about it and because
several projects had come apart a big
studio picture that I'd written for a
major star came apart I wasn't going to
direct that so I was actually kind of
feeling a certain kind of resignation
and my friend Hunter boudin contacted me
and let me know that he had a money
source for making the movie and I had
had the notion about two years before
that of a man getting a suit for his
father's for his for a wedding and
winding up wearing that suit at his
father's memorial and that idea popped
into my head who knows where these ideas
come from
and I had thought of making a movie that
I could shoot very very cheaply so I had
that somewhere in my hopper of ideas so
when I spoke with my friend hunter
boudin who called me and said that he
had a money source do you have an idea
and I said yes I do have an idea and
it's called Bob's new suit and it's
about a guy who gets a suit to get
married in and he winds up wearing it to
his father's memorial and Hunter said
let's go and we were shooting 10 weeks
later and as you know that never happens
so the script was written very very
quickly and it had to come out of the
unconscious
had to just trust what came because when
you have a money source you're of course
concerned that it's gonna go away so you
must move fast and I did and you were
held at the time I was 57 no no no no I
was 67 Oh 60 67 67 yeah and how did it
feel to actually see something happen
you know just you said you'd had these
ideas for years and there then stops and
starts before and so now 67 68 whenever
you finally see this thing come to
fruition how does that feel it felt
great it was it felt great it it made me
very very happy I was we move through
pre-production very quickly and then we
were shooting and I was very happy
driving to the location every morning
yeah I mean it was my lifelong dream and
I had been very very close to it for
many decades and finally there I was did
you almost feel like it wasn't real like
it might go away no because no I felt it
felt very real yeah yeah yeah very very
real what would you tell someone else
who's realized the dream maybe later in
life you know and and so many people you
hear in this town hey if you're over 35
or 40 like don't even try and that's
that's still so so young but what would
you tell someone that's beyond an age
where sometimes you know Hollywood is
just was very strict about so many
different things there's different
unwritten rules about who makes it and
who does what and what would you tell
someone I would tell them that either
they will be able to keep trying or they
won't and it's truly it I don't think
it's a decision that can be made I think
it's organic and it comes out of you
either you keep going up to bat or you
it's certainly what I tell young people
who want to be actors don't do it unless
you're compelled to do it because it's
too rough and I think that that's true
in really any any branch of filmmaking
that it has to come from desire real
desire and how does someone know that
they're compelled to do it rather than
it's their ego or what they think they
should be doing how do they really know
well by the continuation of doing it
despite the odds despite what people
tell you despite the fears that you may
have at 4:00 in the morning when you
can't sleep that you keep doing it and
you know that's how I made I'm just made
that way
you